all right Maggie is with us in Lancaster
Pennsylvania hey Maggie your question
for Rachel Cruise I Rachel
congratulations on your new book hey
Maggie oh thanks so much I appreciate
that all right so a woman a woman I got
a question for you yes I'm 27
single I'm currently on baby steps 4 & 6
and I'm really proud of the progress
I've made so far as you know sure like I
got it goin on right totally yeah you're
sounding great yes
however most of the guys I meet and what
they they seem to be intimidated by that
or and/or has a really cavalier attitude
about that money so my question for you
is how did you know that Winston was the
right financial partner for you what the
right financial partner for me well I
would say when you're dating in general
I think the topic of money needs to come
up but I would say it probably needs to
come up further down the road when it's
getting more serious because actually
and Winston always like Rachel do you
always have to use the story and I do
because it's a perfect example
Winston paid for the first few dates on
a credit card I'm with Rachel Ramsey
it's true so daughter he the old capital
one card paid for a few of our dates and
so I honestly I remember him pulling out
a credit card for our very first date
and I was like oh he's he has a credit
card I mean like this is happening right
now and I thought you know I like the
guy who pulled out a little morals are
true his morals he's a solid ups and I I
was attracted to him all the things are
going and I'm like you know I'm not
gonna like blow him off just because he
has a credit card right now now if we
get married one day yeah we're gonna
have that discussion as the as the
relationship progresses but I did not
just cut him off at the beginning and
I'm so glad I didn't obviously we got
married and so I would say the topic of
money is so so crucial to be on the same
page and I would say it gets more
crucial very very crucial when you're
when it's leading up to marriage and so
I would say for the guys that are
intimidated I think that's a little
strange they probably have I would think
some you know maturity issues because I
would think if a guy was looking at a
girl's like well you've done really well
you've been responsible he's a little
amazing I mean but really you yet
he's intimidated by girls got a rack
together he's a wood well ok bye Uncle
Dave Uncle Dave I got a question for you
then when are you going to be putting
together a dating service I'm not that
sure you have money that's all for the
love of money we had a discussion we had
a discussion with the eHarmony folks at
one point trying to get them to do a
section on this because it's so
requested but we don't think we're
probably not but it's a cute idea I love
pretty harmony to pick it up and do it I
mean I don't need I don't need money
money for it I would just refer it to
them because we have so many requests so
many people want to do it but it's it's
I it's very cool so yeah I am uh my son
is single and watching my girls go
through picking out wonderful young men
Maggie I do not envy any of you that are
in the dating process it's uh it's slim
pickings out there you got a really
you're looking for a you're looking for
a prince among a bunch of frogs and so
but they're there they're there the my
girls both found them and you can find
them and you know that that they found
them connected to Christian
organizations often times because we're
Christians and so that helped us to help
to find people with value systems that
lined up and then both the young men
were humble and smart and strong and you
know adopted the Ramsey way of handling
money but it wasn't like a mandate or
something but they just said oh yeah I
make sense I'm going to do that both
were actually more frugal than their
wives like me and all that strong we
spend more than bill and Winston do and
so so honest they don't write actually
you say more than bill Winston and Bill
and goodbye yeah that might be true do
you spend money but but anyway the yeah
but you're right they naturally
gravitated to yes so so all that to say
though I think the money conversation
comes into play when the when the
relationship gets more and more serious
but don't write someone off at the very
beginning Joe how long how many dates
were you in once before you start
talking about credit cards because he
obviously did not know you were
connected to me he didn't know who you
were no that's fine
here to Google you awesome later on yeah
I don't know he was probably we were in
college so I'm that's the things I
really don't remember because I think it
was such a fluid gradual thing and it
was how many was the white reason he was
yeah one is to get his credit score may
I only kind of connected up and realized
what was going on with with me in the
whole Ramsey thing in all that stuff no
one Winston he probably oh I need to
stop doing that you probably never said
it to him yeah I wouldn't even say it
was cuz of you I'm sure you're sure you
read through this stuff okay that makes
sense I don't need to be my brother
school rock you scared of me that
wouldn't want a minute yeah okay cuz
because I said so that's no he never he
never no not Winston no you're not
scared of me hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right kind of better than the Dave
Ramsey channel don't tell them I said
that
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you